we'll be starting in about one minute
and hello welcome to why building a
successful career
is like building a startup
this is a career master class from
simply learn
and our guest today is tn hari
the head of hr at big basket more about
him in a moment
first how to participate in the webinar
just quickly
uh the question mark button allows you
to enter questions
for our panelists today
uh hari will be joined by krishna kumar
the founder and ceo
of simply learn and if you enter your
questions we will get to those
at the q a section at the end of the
presentation
you can also enter chat with the
speech bubble and use all panelists to
make sure
that krishna and hari see the message
and we'll be taking some of those live
during the presentation
and now to introduce tian hari the head
of hr at big basket
he's also adviser to arkham ventures and
fundamentum
an advisor and sounding board to
numerous young entrepreneurs
and startups the co-founder of infinite
uh with 18 years in high-tech startups
after 14 years at tata steel
author of four books with two more
coming soon
and welcome hari and take it away
krishna
thank you stewart thank you stuart and
thank you hari for
joining us it's an absolute pleasure to
have you on board
so hari i um i'm sure a lot of attendees
already know you
uh know you so i have a set of questions
that i want to ask you
but before that you wanted to talk about
first your thoughts on this topic so
we'll start with that and then i i have
some questions that i want to ask you
and then i will also let all the
audience ask you the questions that they
are willing
i'm sure they are waiting for the moment
to ask you so
look forward to hearing hari great thank
you krishna
so i think what i will do is maybe i
will just uh you know share some of my
own thoughts and then we can follow it
up with
q a so the topic is really i picked is
building a carrier is like building a
successful startup
and you know when faced with the
challenge of explaining an idea that is
inherently difficult to comprehend a
very powerful approach
is to use an analogy from a different
context that is more easily
comprehensible
and then use that understanding to
create clarity around the original idea
and storytellers you know marketeers
have used this for centuries
so i am using the same tool which is
storytelling
you know from a different context which
is how do you build your startups and
then
see the parallels to building your
carrier
so i think you know the first thing i
would say about building a great startup
is that you need to build
good habits in good times and i think a
lot of startups what they try to do is
when bad times hit them they try and
develop good habits
so i think good habits are difficult to
build in difficult times good habits
need to be built in good times
and good habits could be about you know
running a frugal business
building the startup sustainably crazily
focusing on customers
so that you know they are loyal to you
in all the times
crazily focused on employees building a
nice culture
so these are all good habits that
startups need to build in good times
itself
not wait for the bad times to do this
and similarly individuals also need to
develop certain good
habits i would say which will go on to
hold them you know stand by them
in difficult times and the first habit
is just being very professional
and professional can just mean you know
responding to emails on time
returning calls you know saying good
things about
others when needed not hesitating to say
i don't know giving credit to others
when it is due
being truthful trying to meet
commitments responsibility
being curious learning all the time
upskilling continuously to the extent
possible
associating with good people associating
with good organizations these are all
good habits
and i think many of them you know are
can be cultivated some of them are
inherent some people inherently tend to
be more curious than the others
some people tend to inherently you know
learn more than the others but i think
with some practice all of us can
cultivate how to be a little more
professional little more curious
little more you know learning oriented
constantly upscaling
trying to associate with good people and
i think these are something that you can
cultivate and very very important i
would say in time in terms of building a
carrier
i also you know i'm fascinated by you
know
concept of saying no to jugaad which is
you know saying no to jugaad
in building your startup and saying no
to jugaad in terms of building your
carrier as well
and saying no to jugaad is about you
know taking shortcuts shortcuts is
jugaad
jugaad is not frugal innovation a lot of
people seem to think that jugaad is
frugal innovation if you see it that way
there's nothing wrong because
frugal innovation is very critical for
scaling your startup
but i think you know jugaad is more
about taking shortcuts and making
shortcuts as a practice
and inherently what happens is that in
the short term it might give you some
benefits
but eventually in the long term it comes
to bite back in a very big way let me
just give you a very simple example
so every company for instance has a
policy against harassment
specifically let's say is prevention of
sexual harassment
now what happens when you're top
salesperson who brings in 20 to 30
percent of your revenue
and is responsible for growth is accused
of harassment
and on investigation you find that
whatever is
has been accused is right what do you do
do you
you know backtrack do you you know drag
your feet
you don't take action or do you take
swift action
so i think if you drag your feet maybe
you will get some short-term benefits
because he's bringing in the deals
but eventually it will create such a bad
reputation for the firm
that good people will not join to join
you half the workforce which is women
will not see
your organization or your startup as a
safe place to work as a good place to
work
and even people within your organization
may not be happy with your approach
so i think this holds true for carriers
as well
i think the kind of jobs that you pick
the kind of role changes that you seek
the kind of changes in organizations
that you seek should be for a bigger
purpose for a bigger cause
as long as you make these switches for
short-term benefits for slight increase
in cash for a promotion for a
designation
i think they will come to harm you in a
big way so i think it's important to you
know pick your career based on your
anchors
based on your strengths make the right
changes for the right reasons whether
within the company or outside the
company
i think that's relevant i'll now just
switch to a little
slightly different concept which is you
know marshall goldsmith saying all of us
have heard this which is
what got you here won't get you there
and the counter to this
is that if you forget what got you here
you will never get anywhere
and both of these i'll tell you are
important and the first let me come to
the second one because it's more
fundamental
if you forget what got you here you will
never get anywhere which means that you
need to stay grounded
all of us learn lessons in life we go
through some difficult experiences
and then i know when somebody else you
know who is more popular more
influential
tells us something which is counter to
that we are quick
in changing our opinion i think it's
important to remember
our lessons well and remember stay
grounded
and not just be carried away by the
latest fad that's about being grounded
and remembering your lessons and
remembering where you come from
the other part which he himself has said
which is that what got you here won't
get you there which is that
you need to learn new skills constantly
and you need to learn new things what
got you to become a great individual
contributor
may not take you to being a great people
manager may not take you to
being a great cxo so you need to add on
new skills
so i think that side both of them are
critical it's important to be grounded
it's important to also have your wings
and fly
i think walter mitchell was the person
who wrote this famous book called the
marshmallow test
and he had conducted an experiment he's
an austrian american
psychiatrist psychologist who conducted
an experiment that lasted
maybe a couple of decades he took a
bunch of young children
and conducted a test which is he told
them you know what you can take a
marshmallow today
or if you're willing to you know say no
today i'll give you two marshmallows one
week from now
so he was basically checking for the
ability to defer gratification
and then what he did was he followed
these bunch of children
in their career later on and as they
evolved into adults
and he found a very strong beautiful
correlation which is that
those who were able to defer
gratification
where the individuals who tended to be a
little more successful in life
and therefore he concludes that book by
saying the biggest secret for ultimately
happy life
is the development of self-control so in
some ways i think it's important
to develop this degree of self-control
therefore gratification
because a lot of things you know good
things happen if you can defer
gratification
gratification for money justification
for position
if you focus on getting the knowledge
focus on learning new things
then i think they will get you the
long-term benefits
i'll also talk a little bit about you
know these
changes that steps goes through and
phase changes that
you know individuals and carriers go
through so for example
there is a very famous model by larry
greener he wrote this in
a harvard business a new article he said
typically startups
go through five phases of evolution from
being a very early stage startup to
being
a mature firm and he beautifully
identifies what these star
you know different cases are i've been
with startups for 18 years and in the
beginning you know
i tended to figure out that there is
something that is changing in the
startup that i am working
i could not clearly figure out but i
sense that something is changing
and as i read his article it was a big
aha moment for me
you know everything fell into place in
the penny dropped he says the first
stage of growth is growth through
direction which is the founder has a
brilliant
idea and growth happens because of the
idea itself
so it is the idea which results in
growth nothing else
you have a disruptive idea customers
love it are willing to pay for it
the founder does not need anything else
and the startup will go
up to a particular point but beyond that
point if the startup is to progress
then the founder needs to learn basics
of management
which is how to hire a tech organization
how to conduct interviews how to give
feedback how to do basics of marketing
how to do frugal marketing
how to keep my books of account so
unless the founder begins to learn of
these things
the startup begins to break so the
founder learns all of these things
and then the next phase of growth is the
founder telling everybody else
this is the way we do things here which
is growth through direction telling
everyone
this is how we market this is how we
hire our tech folks this is the way we
conduct
interviews but the startup again
struggles because
good people are not willing to join this
startup because the founder is telling
everyone what to do whereas good people
want to come in
and do what they know best so the
founder
bridges this and goes beyond it then the
founder begins to delegate
which is give freedom to people
empower them and then growth happens
because of delegation
but when growth happens because of
delegation then what happens is that
small little empires begin to get built
small different subcultures begin to get
built because you hire people
leaders from different organizations
they come from different backgrounds
they have seen different success stories
different contexts and each of them
believes that their experience is the
best experience
so delegation after some point the
results in chaos
resources are not shared people build
their own
independent organizations as a result of
which you know cost structures begin to
go up
at that point of time if the founder
understands this and gets to the next
level
the founder begins to bring everyone
together through good coordination
which is putting the right kind of
dashboards together
which is you know getting people to
share resources sharing information
sharing you know one another's goals
with the team as such
so this results in very good
coordination but it also creates a bit
of bureaucracy
which is essential at this point of time
because if that's not there then the
organization will just break apart
because of centrifugal forces
so it creates a bureaucracy but it keeps
organization together
but at the next phase is about
collaboration how do you create
people to work in teams and innovate
well without the necessary without the
bureaucracy
that happens when the organization
begins to collaborate in a very informal
way
so i've seen these phases very clearly
in the organization that i've worked for
but it was an intuitive understanding
and when i read this article everything
fell into place
and you can see some parallels in
carriers as well which is all
our start you know by being dependent
all of us start by being individual
contributors
all of us start you know by applying
whatever little knowledge we have to the
work we do
the next phase of our growth is
independence
how do you how do you be professional
how do you
take decisions on your own how do you
not ask
for guidance too much how do you ask for
guidance for the right amount neither
too little not too much
how do you escalate the right time
neither too late nor too early
so it is from dependence to independence
you get
and finally to progress in your career
you need to understand that independence
is not enough you need to get to
interdependence how do you work in a
network
how to influence people who are not part
of your team how do you influence
people you know to believe in your ideas
how do you sell ideas how do you
collaborate on complex issues and build
unanimity how do you create
you know a collision of support for your
ideas
so that's about interdependence the
career is also about
developing these skills from being
dependent
being very professional applying
knowledge to work
and then it's about independence which
is applying a lot more knowledge
across functions across teams delegating
providing guidance and then it's finally
about interdependence which is about
influencing in a very big way so i think
this
is an analogy as well interesting one
the next one i would like to provide is
that startups always
invariably tend to make some pivots at
the right point of time
so those who've been with startups
figure out you know what is a pivot
it comes from basketball actually in
basketball pivot is you know you keep
one foot firmly on the ground
and swivel around that foot move the
second foot in the air
so that you are able to pass or take a
shot by avoiding a defender
and the same thing applies in a startup
as well and there's so many cases
of pivots that have happened you know
every single company that you
think can think of including your own
startup you must have done multiple
pivots you know the companies i've
worked for me multiple pivots make my
trip which many of you would recognize
made a big pivot from just being
you know airlines you know bookings uh
travel company to doing hotels they
realize that airlines is not going to
give them margins because
their bargaining power was not high
because the number of airlines was very
few
and therefore their bargaining part was
not high but hotels was completely
disaggregated and therefore there was an
opportunity to
you know bring them on this platform so
every startup you know figures out that
you need to make a pivot at some point
of time if things are not going well
and a pivot is about staying you know
on one core competence one core ability
one core customer segment
keeping that constant making changes and
a few other things
and that could be about you know
addressing adjacent customers providing
a slightly different service it could
mean any of those things and pivots
happen in your career as well
you know i made multiple pivots i was
the hardcore engineer mechanical
engineer working on the shop floor with
the hard hat and the steel company
pivoted to hr within a steel company
working with trade unions
and more than hr it was really working
with trade unions
and then pivoting to hr in startups so
i think all of us make these pivots so
one anchor is very important
and therefore you need to figure out
what is your anchor
sometimes you might wonder you know what
is my anchor is it easy to figure out
what my
anchors are i think if you think very
honestly
it's easy to figure out what your
anchors are there are always those
signals
so for example one anchor could be
whatever has given
you success in life and success in life
could be as
in your student days college days in
your early careers
what has given you success are you
successful because you're a great
communicator
are you successful because you are a
terrific thinker clear thinker
or are you successful because you
execute really well
so if you think very deeply you will
figure out that there
are some anchors that have resulted in
your success
and those are important to remember
because you should always try and stay
with some of those
other ways to figure out for instance
what is your anchor
is if you are in the midst of an
activity and if you lose a sense of time
and after that activity is over you feel
like doing it again
and you're waiting for the next
opportunity to do that again
then that's clearly your anchor for
example
if i'm in a problem solving session
white boarding session and that can be
about any type of a problem
i lose sense of time and therefore
you know at the end of the session i'm
always waiting for when is the next
problem-solving opportunity so clearly
for me one of my anchors is
problem solving so if you think about
this what has given you success
you know by doing what you are not able
to figure out the time is passing
what are those activities you volunteer
for and want to do again and again
if you figure that out you figure you're
out your anchors
and therefore it's important to keep
that anchor very steady
there are a few people of course who are
able to make dramatic switches in career
some people are able to you know move
from operations to quality assurance
but some people are able to move from
operations to marketing to general
management are able to make those
dramatically different unrelated moves
so those people possess
very high degree of clear thinking
common sense
and an ability to deal with people some
people just make
career changes which are adjacent which
is that from analytics
to you know digital marketing or digital
marketing to data sciences they make
those related switches where there is
some core competence depots and which is
about data which is about numbers
but they're able to make some switches
to adjacent you know domains but some
people make
switches to very very unrelated domain
so you need to figure out
and where what kind of switches you are
capable of making i think and you should
be honest about that because if you're
not honest
then you will end up doing the wrong
things you will end up pursuing things
for which
you are not competent you will not have
self-awareness
and you know what people say you know
individuals have got
burnt out they get burnt out in startups
i will tell you that burnout never
happens if you
are enjoying what you're doing burnout
only happens if you're doing something
that you don't enjoy day in and day out
every day if you're doing something that
you are not enjoying you will burn out
in no time
so for example if you give me a sales
job the job that requires to go out and
sell to people
i will burn out in no time because
that's not my skill and i will
acknowledge that up front always i've
acknowledged it
i've never taken anything that has got
to do with selling so i think it's
however well it pays however cool it may
be however easy
it may be to get to a ceo through the
sales and marketing route
if you're not fit to do that don't do it
because you will then burn out
so i think it's important to find your
anchors find
what you like find what you're good at
and then pursue that
and you know what uh the last couple of
points i'll make
warren buffett you know had said that in
investing
when others are greedy that's when you
should you know
not be greedy which is that if others
are you know stock markets are going up
crazily you should be selling
the stock markets are falling crazily
that's when probably you should be
buying which is contrarian behavior is
good
so i would say a carrier it really means
that not necessarily going with the
crowd
so i think uh going with the crowd going
with the herd
is deeply ingrained into the human brain
it has almost become part of evolution
there's so much of evolutionary muscle
behind it following the crowd
you know becomes the norm it happened
you know
in this it happens in business schools
it happens in schools
where everybody wants to do engineering
because
their friends are doing engineering and
i found so many people after one
semester
figure out that engineering is not their
cup of tea at all they figure out
marketing was not the cup of tea they
took electives unnecessarily
some people figured out that you know
they should have done this but they
didn't do it
so i think try and avoid going with the
crowd try and avoid
you know just chasing you know whatever
is in fashion
and do whatever is the right thing by
you
and the last point i'll make is that
if you change jobs in a career do that
for the right reason
which is that ask yourself will this
help me learn new skills
will this help me develop new
competencies
can i leverage my strengths and do
something which will create
impact on scale so i think those are all
the things that
you should look for when you change your
job when you look for a new job you
shouldn't be looking at something
because
it pays you more and you know what i've
always seen that
when i've you know done hiring for a
living
for several years and when i look at a
resume and if i see that
people have spent two to two two and a
half three one and a half years in roles
it gives me itself a big red flag for me
because it almost tells me that
they're changing jobs for the wrong
reason or that they have been identified
as not performing which means that it
took two years
for you to be discovered that you are
not a performer
and then you ran away before you know
you got discovered
so i think you know it's important to
stay in a place warren buffett said
you know what hold on long-term
investing is what matters because you
need to hold on to stocks don't sell at
the slightest you know dip
don't get worried when stock markets
fall if your fundamentals are correct
if the stocks that you invested have
sound fundamentals because stock markets
will go up eventually
good right stocks will go up the same
thing about your carrier as well
make the right investments hold on to
them for sufficient period of time
because
it takes sufficient amount of time to
build
deep capabilities these capabilities
don't come very easily
you need to be at it you need to work
hard you need to you know dirty
your hands you need to roll up your
sleeves you
need to get some stuff done and one of
the other things that i keep hearing
from time to time you know even startups
is that
you know what you are this job is not
giving me anything exciting it's not
adding to the cv it is not strategic i'm
doing tactical stuff
every day i'm doing boring stuff and how
will it help me in my career
so real thing is that you know no not
there's nothing like strategy
is always learnt in the context of
execution
i can give you so many examples i think
i'll give you one simple example that i
just encountered
in one of the companies that i was
working for we were small at some point
of time
and in 2015 this was a three city
company this is big basket
and there was not much of travel
involved and we had a very small travel
desk manned by one individual
and then suddenly we decided to expand
into 25 cities tier two cities
and then suddenly travel increased
dramatically we had to open new offices
get new warehouses hire new people get
new teams
interviews so travel increased
dramatically
and then suddenly we found out that make
my trip yatra
all the travel companies refused to
provide his services whenever some
people used to travel to a tier two city
in india vijayawada vishakapattam
chandigarh
they would find in the middle of the
night that the hotel tells them no room
is being put for you the cab would not
turn up
we figured out we had not paid the
invoices and then the travel executive
walked away
and then we opened the desk of the
travel exactly we found piles and piles
of invoices
and then we called one lady and told her
you know what we know you have a day job
to do
can you fix this because this is a very
important thing for the company
my response was you know what this is
[ __ ] that somebody else has created
why should i clean it up and how will it
add to my cv what is it strategic in
this
and by the way if you if i do this will
you give me a special bonus
then we called the second lady and her
response was you know what
tell me how much time do you give me and
he said you have a week's time
do i have any resources for this sorry
we said we don't have any if you want
you can hire an intern
she got an intern and fixed this problem
in seven days
did she do strategic stuff absolutely
she did strategic stuff
because looking at those hundreds of
thousands of invoices
she had to take some decisions because
there was no evidence
that a person had actually traveled and
utilized the service which was being
invoiced
so she had to look at some data which
was incomplete and take some decisions
get management approvals
and put in place processes that would
ensure that such a thing would never
happen
again so therefore in the context of
this dirty work
she figured out some strategic stuff so
such things are very important so you
know
the attitude is very critical which is
that you learn strategy you learn the
good stuff
only in the context of execution
and i'll just talk about one last thing
before we can open it up
i think this last thing is in a startup
you know
people suddenly get exposed because
the competency required in a job
increases much faster than an individual
can build a competency because
the ability for individuals to grow in
capability
is something but if the startup grows
much faster than that and the demand
that places on the individual
is much more than what the individual
can grow to provide
then this individual is going to fail on
the job so it is important to realize
that there's nothing wrong with
me feeling it's something that you know
is natural because organization has
grown so rapidly
so in such a situation what happens in
startups is that some people suddenly
find themselves
out of debts so for example a company my
startup might hire a head of operations
but when suddenly the operations grow
the product market fit is terrific
and the company begins to expand very
rapidly
this individual may be out of depth in
which case
then the company may choose to bring in
vp operations who has handled scale
before
then how does this original head of
operations deal with this
how does the startup deal with this
individual so i think a sensible
individual will always figure out that
you know it's not the right thing for me
to continue to do this because it's not
a downgraded thing
the company getting a vp is not a
downgradation for me in fact it's an
opportunity for me to learn how to
handle operations on scale
under guidance in fact it gives me you
know a safety net
i am not going to fail and therefore it
places me in a position of strength
a wrong way of thinking about this could
be that
you know what the company does not trust
me anymore and therefore they've gotten
somebody
i used to talk to the founder every day
now i know no longer can talk to the
founder every day i don't need the
founder every day
so i think you know taking the attitude
in some kind of situation like this is
very helpful
but some individuals still don't
understand it and they choose to move on
but in your career i think
self-realization
self-awareness awareness of what you're
good at awareness of what you're not
good at
awareness of at what point of time you
should give way to somebody else at what
point of time you should
continue and persevere they are all
important lessons
so as i said that there are a lot of
parallels between startups parallels
between good investing and parallels
with career building so let me pause
here at this point of time i think we've
been 13 minutes
and then i think we can take questions
so hari i think there was a very
terrific
speech i think i i learned a lot during
this process and um
it was a lot of wisdom and i also
reading out a lot of comments and i
think a lot of people are
really writing a lot of things that i
wish their managers were
listening to this and some of the people
also said that this sounds like
a great um speech and they want to
listen more and more of this source
so definitely there's a lot of audience
who enjoyed uh listening to you
and i wanted to ask you a few questions
and i'll take up some of those questions
uh from the audience
some of the questions that i had listed
have already covered but i'll again
uh touch base those questions with some
kind of twist so first thing that i want
to ask you is that you went to iit you
did mechanical engineering
then you went to im also and then you
become hr professional
i think this is a very unusual
combination during your time i think
hr was definitely not a top profession
that anyone used to aspire to
especially the kind of hr that you just
started like dealing with with
trade union yeah that appears to be a
very dangerous thing to do
so yeah how did you realize that this is
your calling or this is your anchor
and you decided to move from shop floor
to dealing with trade unions and
so-called
i think it could be called some
something else it was not called hr it
was called something else right
industrial relations so how did you guys
get into that
that's a good point krishna so i think
uh one of my anchors has been curiosity
so i think you know i was interested in
school days in physics and that took me
to engineering
at the same time i was also interested
in things like literature history
and i continued my interest in history
and to the even today i think when i
write books you know i've been writing
some books and i've been able to draw a
lot from history
so you know i did my mba not to get a
foothold outside of engineering but to
get a more holistic understanding of how
organizations work
and therefore i wanted to do take up an
engineering job after i
left i am so i took up a job at tata
steel i didn't join international trade
which entailed a lot of foreign
travel i took up a job on the shop floor
working in co carbons built one of the
first
you know by-product plants for treating
carbon gas
i enjoyed it a great deal at some point
of time in large companies they also
rotate you
as i told you you know they rotate
people sometimes with your high
potential into unrelated areas and this
happens in many large companies
including companies like ibm
if you're a high potential they tend to
rotate you into unrelated areas so that
you can become a general manager
and therefore one of the areas that i
picked was hr because
i liked the vp hr and i found him a very
interesting
person very high quality person who was
very empowering in his
life style very delegating in the style
very warm in his style
so i liked the person and therefore i
took up this role because of that i
could have gone into marketing but i
guess marketing is not my calling
so i wanted to explore something else
you know and i want to explore hr
because it was individual
and then i realized that you know human
capital is actually a very interesting
area it is
for many reasons you know people don't
fully understand it and i
realize why they don't understand it
that's because
human capital has is not a specialized
area like engineering or laws
and therefore you don't need to study hr
to be able to work in hr
and i have found that the best hr people
are those who come from other functions
not those people who studied hr formerly
done in mba in hr because those people
typically lack you know real you know
grounding in business so i realized that
you know
human capital is a very interesting area
if you bring the right perspective if
you bring an understanding of business
it's a very exciting field
and then i also realized that tata steel
somehow was not the place for me because
i was a bit of a rule breaker
i was more of you know an entrepreneur
within the company
and i realized a large company tends to
be bureaucratic you need to
take approval from 10 people before
doing something so
it was looking out it was just by
accident that i joined
this company called so sometimes you
know what in a career i would also say
that
you just need to get a little lucky if i
hadn't got lucky i would be languishing
at other scenes so i think you know
sometimes you need to get a little lucky
and that was my element of luck
and to tell you a story of luck i kept
trying i
never gave up i never gave up looking
out and i just got lucky to meet
the right organization for me because
there's been no turning back
so i think very great point so first
i'll also agree with you that in in
today's world for sure
i think if there is something which is
after ceo if the ceo is the person who
drives an organization to
whichever direction he or she wants to
drive the next important role is a chat
because in knowledge
industry your company is defined by the
kind of people that you have on the
board and hr is a person that is
overall responsible for getting the
right kind of team members
within the organization so today is
definitely that important but
but great to know that you you found
that guy very charismatic and he
pulled you to that particular profession
also i agree that
startups sometimes get lucky that they
choose the right field they choose the
right technology
they go after the right opportunity
because every time you are always given
up
you always have choice of multiple
opportunity and then you take
the remaining opportunity sometimes you
get lucky inspecting those opportunities
sometimes you
fail miserably right so i think you need
to have a little bit of luck so
completely agree to that point now uh
hari you have the distinction of working
into three kinds of companies you have
worked a really large company like
[ __ ] still you have worked in uh at
least two companies that i am aware of
doc
became part of ibm yeah big market that
started small and became
one of the largest uh company in that
space in india
so startup that became quite big and
then you've also worked in couple of
startups that remain a startup and
they're acquired like taxes
and so on yeah so we have to give career
advice to people who are
in these three types of organizations
startup that that is still a startup
startup that they suddenly became big
and and a company that is already very
big and there is an employee who is
working in these three companies
and if they have to plan their career if
you are giving this advice to an
individual working in these three types
of companies
is your advice going to be different how
do you look at
uh thinking how do you see those
employees thinking about the curry like
for example i saw one of the
question asked by someone that i worked
in a large company for eight years
and i was taken for granted i got a
bigger bigger salary height
i was not recognized and so on whereas
there are other
comments saying that why should i work
for more than two years
uh in an organization because i'm losing
an opportunity i can
jump every two years get into another
company get high maybe get
exposed to different kind of challenges
also so what what is your advice
depending on who the person is and which
kind of company is working
yeah so frankly uh uh krishna when i
picked uh dutch as well as big basket
they were small companies they were not
the companies that they are today
so for example in just in terms of
valuation though valuation may not be
the perfect metric
it was less than 200 million dollars
when i joined uh
big basket daksh was a 1500 people
organization when i joined
when i quit after about four years it
was about 25 000 people
spread across multiple countries so when
i joined these companies they were small
i think um it just happened that these
two became really big but user also
became big but
was also a small company we listed the
company in nasdaq so that was a success
story
whereas taxi for sure and amba were
relatively small they got acquired
but i think i enjoyed my journey in all
of these five so
my advice would uh to people would
depend upon
what kind of environment do you like big
basket currently is a large company it's
a stable environment
i think while there is innovation it is
not
the you know small early stage startup
kind of a situation the chaos is not
great people have work-life balance
you know people don't have to work for
crazy hours there is not so much of
uncertainty the business model is very
steady
it is now about you know just being able
to grow
whereas in the early days everything
would have been chaotic so if you love
cures if you love driving keos if that's
the kind of environment you love
then i think an early stage or rapidly
growing startup is good
but if you want little more stability
but don't want the bureaucracy of a very
large company like an accent shop then a
big basket or a duck
at its latest stage is a good place to
work so i think a place like big basket
provides you an opportunity to innovate
it is a
you know semi startup and at the same
time is not a large company so i think
it gives you stability
and allows you to innovate but if you
really want to
grow rapidly then i think an early stage
start because
an early stage startup is always
starving for talent
so if you are really good then they
begin to depend upon you
you can get promoted very rapidly you
can become the if you're in product if
you demonstrate
amazing abilities you can even become a
head of product and if you can continue
to scale your abilities along with the
company scale
you could choose to continue to remain
the head of product they will not hire a
vp above you
because you are growing as rapidly as
the startup itself
so i think uh you know it depends upon
what you really like
some people like you know good work-life
balance big basket is a good place
to work you want a good work-life
balance but the smaller ones maybe
are chaotic you know making constant
pivots
changing priorities every day today
revenue growth tomorrow profitability
laying off some people you know so i
think it depends upon
the individual sorry what about uh that
large one if someone is thinking about
building their career
and have and today happens to be in one
of those large companies that you talked
about
what will be your advice to them do you
think that it's like practically
impossible to build a great career in
one of these large emergencies
oh no no of course not of course not so
i think you know frankly i i'm not
implying that at all
so i think there are some people who are
good in large companies
and uh you know many i've seen a lot of
people
who have joined large companies continue
to grow in large companies some of them
have become ceo's one of my batchmates
narendra he did well in a large company
tried in a large company
it's just that i did not like working
for a large company but there are many
people who are carrier ibm's they will
never quit ibm
they will reach some of them will reach
middle management level some of them
will
reach senior management some of them
will become cxos
but they are happy working in that kind
of a company
because it provides so many benefits you
know you can work from home
they will take you to you know different
offices across
ibm in the world you can get global
experience
you can get to work with global teams
you can work on
building very impactful products
so it depends upon the individual people
are very very successful careers
broadly you know what intuitively i
classify people as is this person a
large company individual or a small
company person
some people inherently the large company
people and even after
doug she got acquired by ibm i have
found that you know some of them
even after 18 years continue with ibm
and they're thriving in ibm
so they were you know business heads
some of them in dak
but they continued they didn't quit uh
ibm and they're doing very well
so i think you can build your career
even large companies in fact large
companies are places where traditionally
people have built carriers startups are
just
relatively recent i would say i think
large companies traditionally is where
people
thought they could build careers for the
long term okay
so i think uh hari were talking about
large carbon a small company so one of
the best that i have seen in the startup
world
based on my experience is that when they
hire when the young companies are
startups higher
they typically prefer hiring from
another young company or so called
startup they are they are little
concerned when it comes to hiring from a
like of an ibm because i think that it
will be a
cultural misfit and i think the same
over worry is on the on the employee
side also people who work in large
company
when they make switches they make to
another large company have you seen
many successes where small company
people have gone to a large company and
they have
done very well and vice versa i have
seen um
yes both examples i have seen but not
many uh so i've seen for example i give
you the example just some time back that
people from daksh some of the business
head
after acquisition by ibm continued with
ibm for 18 years
and still are with ibm and have made a
big success of it so from large small
company to large company
these are clear examples and i have seen
people from large companies to small
companies i myself have come from a
large company to smaller companies and i
think i've
been able to adjust and adapt reasonably
well and there are quite a few i think
we've been able to adapt
but i think the problem or the mindset
is
quite genuine because what happens is
that sometimes when startups are
on the verge of scaling and taking off
in a big way
they think that by hiring people who
have handled scale
they will be able to deal with scale but
that's not necessarily true
and i think there's a fine difference
between managing in a scale environment
in a large company
and building for scale the two are
completely different
managing in a scale environment means
that there are a lot of support
structures you have people to do things
for you you might not have
the ability to put pen to paper and get
things yourself
done but you know it's important in a
startup to be able to put pen to paper
how do you build for scale you can't
build for scale unless you can put pen
to paper and develop the right processes
yourself
you know hire your team do the
interviews and get things done
so i think i've seen some examples you
know where and these are real examples
and one of the startups that i've worked
for
this was a you know kpo knowledge
process outsourcing company
we were going you know globally the big
way the founders were selling
you know in the us and europe to clients
but they did not know the
sales process well enough so we were
thinking getting a global head of sales
and we got a global head of sales
eventually from a
big company and there were a lot of red
flags in the hiring process
and none of us you know objected all of
us you know silently accepted it none of
us raised
uh our fears concerns about these red
flags the false consensus got built
and we hired this guy in no time we had
to let this person go in less than six
months we had to let this person go
because this guy just could not build
for scale the way he saw things
he could not deal with the skills so i
think if you consume a large company is
good but you should be able to
adjust with this chaotic workplace you
should be able to understand and work
with the early stage employees
who have built a reputation who have you
know solved real problems
in the zero to one stage you should
appreciate them respect and build mutual
trust
demonstrate some skills that they don't
have because you don't demonstrate
skills that they don't have in value
then they will be worrying why has the
company paid
somebody so much to hire so i think you
know the fear that big company people
can't adjust to small companies and vice
versa
is a genuine fear so i think whenever
you are hiring across
you should be extremely careful and do
reference checks
so i think another question which is
also a little bit um sensitive question
is that i also see a trend wherein when
you're hiring let's say somebody for a
mid manager role
and there are two options both are maybe
equally good candidate
one candidate is less than let's say
about six to eight years of
overall work experience and then another
candidate which is
more like say fifteen to twenty years of
work invariably most of the
hiring managers even though they might
not say that officially
but they will end up hiring the junior
person right and this is also leading to
a lot of people who have
more number of years of experience and
for various reasons they are not get
got to the next level they losing out to
the opportunity that they deserve based
on their current skill set
so how do what kind of advice do you
have people like what kind of advice can
you give it to them
this is a very tough question krishna in
fact you know this really brings us to
another topic which is uh diversity and
inclusion
i think uh diversity and inclusion we
have taken things from a politically
correct
respect we've always have tried to say
politically correct things but the
reality is that
there is some discrimination which
happens based on age and based on
education so job description would say
you know
you need an engineer you need so and so
but you will find some people who may
not have the educational qualifications
who are also very good
but what happens is that you have to
cast your net very wide and therefore
you specify
similarly it comes to age also i think
for example take a
founder who is let's say 28 years old
the founder is unlikely to hire a 45
year old person
to work as a direct report so for
example
as a cto or a chief product officer
somebody who's 45 years old the 20 year
old eight-year-old founder would be
reluctant
the founder might even think you know
what that if 45 year old guy may be good
but why should i spend so much time
adjusting why should i deal with that
risk of whether it will fail or not fail
will we
you know be able to think alike will he
be able to work as fast as
i was will this person be able to cope
will this be able to personally
able to attend late night meetings
because we are a chaotic workplace
so i think some of the fears i think
tend to be a little genuine
but sometimes also i think hiring
managers are a bit insecure so i think
there is a
fine balance part of it is insecurity
which is that
if i hire a seven year experienced
person that person will be easier to
manage
because that person has not seen many
things in life so the person will be
willing to listen to me
whereas somebody who's 15 years old will
have a point of view we'll say
no we'll argue we'll you know have a
contrarian view
so why should i go through all those
difficulties so i think it's partly the
insecurity
so i think partly it is genuine partly i
think it is a
fear of can i manage this experienced
person
i think the reality is that india is a
demographically young nation
and i think a lot of talent from the
youth younger
is pushing and therefore unless a 15
year old is constantly learning
new skills which the seven year
experience does not have and which is i
can tell you very difficult
because just by getting more years of
experience does not mean that
your competence is building up unless
you are thinking unless you're curious
unless you're learning
you your ex competence will not be
really very different from a seven year
experienced person accepting for some
areas in maturity other things you may
not be more competent
so i think you need to that fifteen-year
experienced person should
you know constantly learn otherwise they
will really become redundant
so i think great point hari and i think
so your message is that if you are
as your experience increases you need to
continuously
up skill re-skill and make sure that you
deserve that job otherwise
youngest will push you away he told
about that india is a young
demography and the more talent coming
into the job force every year
unfortunately i have seen that in the
u.s also if you go to a google or a
facebook campus
it looks like a grad school so yeah such
a big one you think that you are in a
campus right because most of the
kids working there are in their early
20s
i wanted to ask you a question that you
you you had touched upon while you were
speaking
which was that um a person has joined a
young company and was doing extremely
well suddenly the workload increases to
a
company grows 10x and the founder
realizes that the person who was doing
very well till date is not good enough
for this
increased skill and he gets someone from
outside yeah two thing happens
there are few people who stick on and
then and they look forward to learning
from from the new person that has come
to take up his own
and there are people who think that okay
i was doing great
for no reason i have been asked to
report to someone else
now the other option that i've seen a
lot of these people do
they go and join another young company
where they are a good fit
so how do you see the decision see from
my perspective i see that
it's about your aspiration if you are
good to be a head of operations for a
100 people company
and suddenly your current company is
becoming a thousand person company and
and your ceo is getting another person
who has seen that kind of skill
either you can decide to aspire to
become the guy who can eventually
handle a thousand people uh organization
ops or be
go and join another 10 people company
and take that 10 people to another 100
right
so from my perspective i think they both
are good decisions it depends upon
who you are what do you enjoy yeah have
you seen this kind of like both
kind of cases for people being
successful or have you seen people who
have made those switches
eventually lamenting that why did they
take that call they could have stayed on
and
been more successful yeah i think you're
right krishna
i've seen a lot of these cases but and
as you said both of these
can be successful but if you ask me to
pick one
and if you ask me to advise somebody on
what is the right thing to do i would
say that
stay on and learn from the most senior
person that the ceo or the founder has
hired
because i think if you really want to
grow in your career it is not about
making those lateral moves and staying
at the same level
for you you can't spend your entire life
you know managing a team of 20
you know just because you you worked
your first startup 20 became 100 but you
could not manage they got a big senior
person so you don't want to
if you go to another company and manage
a team of 20 then in some ways you are
not really growing you just continue to
manage the same
level so your skill level your
competence level is not
growing and i think it's also a question
of attitude i think people who make
these switches
are actually showing an attitude which
will fail them in the long run because
their attitude is one of they get upset
that you know why is that my startup not
trusting me
and they are angry and they quit mostly
out of anger and i think that anger is
not the right
thing to have so i think
coming back to your point i think you
can move from 20 to 20 team
you know smaller startup and continue to
work with them but i think
if in a career is all about building
your competence and growing
your you know your own personality your
ability
i think that comes with doing new things
and managing and learning scheme
got it sorry what i hear you saying is
that you can satisfy your ego by just
giving
you joining another company but if you
really want to grow in your careers
better to learn skills that you don't
have so
bigger skill of scaling yeah one because
another classic
dilemma i see a lot of people go through
while they have to make decision is that
sometimes they are in a good role
and they are really enjoying that role
suddenly they are offered another role
maybe in another company which might not
be as exciting as their current role but
it's it's it's exciting in terms of
payout
so so there's always dilemma should i go
for higher pay now should i continue in
my current job which is exciting
what is your advice on how to draw a
balance i'm sure
it cannot be either or how do you try to
find balance
see the way i have seen this is that you
should never be
overpaid and i think being overpaid i
think
is a wrong strategy in life if you're
paid more than what you deserve
then i think it's inherently wrong
sometimes you can get away nothing may
happen to you
but it's very likely that someday it
will come to bite you which is that
you might be the first person to lose
your job because you know
company is always looking at people who
are highly paid
are they delivering results are they
performing they are under the radar more
than anybody else so let's assume for a
moment that you are looking for
you know a good product person and you
are paying let's say 50 lakhs a good
product had work had leaves
and you find somebody and you know you
that person negotiates and you don't
have your choice you offer this person
100 lakhs
now once you offer this person 100 likes
and this person doesn't deserve that
you are going to keep an eye out on this
individual whether this person is
delivering to that compensation or not
so my very broad advice is that never be
overpaid because
of being overpaid is the wrong thing and
i think if you
focus on learning if you focus on
enjoying what you're doing
then i think you know money will
invariably follow you it might be a
little
delayed in coming but it will follow you
in a very steady way
so that's my broad advice you know in
terms of going after money
and i am also not saying that you know
money is a bad thing and you give up
money completely and you know settle
with himalayas
no i think money is important in life
you have a family to run you have
financial commitment
but i think taking a balanced view of
this not being
you know greedy i think that is what
differentiates in fact you know what
i have found that in interviews
especially at senior levels
the way a manager especially at a very
senior level the way they
deal with compensation negotiation is a
big giveaway about the character of the
person there was one case where a cxo
was rejected
because of the way the person negotiated
compensation
so i think a way a person negotiates
compensation also
gives you deep insights into the
psychology of a person and tells you
the person is good to have in your
company or not sometimes people ask
for you know i used to travel business
class i know but in your company you're
being frugal can you make an exception
for me
so i think if somebody comes to you with
such a request that's a
big big red flag because this individual
does not even care about your company
culture
so i think you know first way for deals
with compensation is
the thing and god advises that it's
important to be paid well but it's
important not to be overpaid
not to be underpaid not to be overpaid
it's a very fine balance don't be greedy
is broadly what i would say
because money will come to you if you're
competent
got it i think you talked about uh
overpaid
how often do you come across candidate
who really believe that they are
overpaid
how do you decide because i think anyway
everybody thinks in the world
they are they are underpaid yeah i think
yeah very few people might think they're
overpaid but i
i think that some people figure out that
they have
you know tricked the system or i think
some people
are really aware i would say the few
people who are really overpaid are also
scared they are aware that they are
overpaid in fact
when there is a slight downturn they are
the people who are the most worried
so i think moderately overpaid they
don't think they are overpaid but those
who are
quite overpaid i think recognize and
realize it
alex said they behave in all the wrong
ways they try to please their boss
they try to suck up to their boss so
that you know they keep their job they
keep the high pay once you're overpaid
you begin to do
funny things which are not professional
which don't demonstrate integrity
sorry next i'll take a question by
sakshi as he's saying that he's planning
to
be a mother soon and ah is becoming he's
taking her career
break during those time a roadblock in
career
and how should she go about planning so
i before you answer i also wanted to
give my answer to her i don't think
being a mother is negative at all i
think for a lot of
roles it's consistently proven that
women do better than men
and on when it comes to taking career
break to to plan a family
my suggestion to you is that see it's
not only a mother's responsibility to
raise a kid
father has also has an equal
responsibility so if you are taking a
break for lets an year
to raise your kid you should also be
prepared your partner should also be
prepared to take another year of career
break right it's not only for you you
can also take a break so
it doesn't become a breakthrough only
one person another person continues
doing
so a lot of people have seen lot of
successful
women that i have seen come across in my
professional career they have planned
that way
but why should only one person take a
break you can plan break together so
then
both the careers go away paddling sorry
your advice what will be your opinion
i have nothing to add this is a
brilliant response question i have
nothing
really very good response so i think
another question that i wanted to ask is
that see most startup
founders and startup companies have
mentors many of them have their some of
the investors joining their board and
they come up with a lot of advice a lot
of experience of
investing in a scaling company many
startups also get
independent directors and get them to
advise so
when it comes to individual how
important is a mentor to them like do
you think that everybody should get a
mentor
and if yes how should they go about
identifying who they can get as a mean
yeah so slightly difficult to answer
this i can talk from some personal
experience
so i think i have interacted with some
people so for example
uh the founder of daksh the first
startup that i've worked for which is
sanjiv agarwal
happens to be my mentor in some ways
very informally happens to be my mentor
it's not that i go to him for advice
ever we don't we rarely speak
but i think we know each other well we
know what we are good at we know
when the other wants to speak we trust
each other completely
so for instance he asked me to join big
basket and i
didn't ask any questions i just joined
big basket
he asked me to if i would be interested
in you know being an advisor at
fundamentum partnership which is the
which is the stage b c b c fun i was
happily
happy to be part of that so i think in
some ways he's been my mentor
but i don't know if he's a mentor mentor
i don't know if i will ever go and ask
him
or discuss any of my problems with him i
don't think i've ever
discussed any of my problems seriously
with him although when we meet we have a
chat on a hunt
a range of things very easily very
freely
but i don't know if i have sought advice
so frankly from a mentor perspective i
think
mentor has to be if i think is important
to have
and i don't know whether it's a mentor
or a friend i think at some point it's
important to have somebody who's seen
the world a little more than you
and uh who you can trust completely who
is not going to judge you and
uh yeah i think that having a mentor i
think multiple mentors is helpful it's
not that just one individual you can go
to for everything
i think for different things you can go
to different individuals so i think you
can have multiple
founding boards mentor may not be the
right word you can have multiple
sounding boards
got it so i think uh very good advice
one last question that i wanted to take
was
you spoke about anchors that you always
have and you find your anchors and then
that help you make the decisions in your
career
how does this anchors change over a
period of time like do you have
something else maybe attractive in the
beginning of your career then some
it changes something else is it quite
common or
more or less is the same throughout your
careers yeah i think uh
very good question this is i think there
have been always two schools of thought
one school of thought and i think i come
somewhere in between one school of
thought is that
you are who you are your strengths don't
change much
over your entire life you might become a
little more refined
you might you know you know brush off
some of your weaknesses you might
learn to you know round off some of
these sharp edges
but your strengths remain what they are
essentially and you are who they
you are that's one point of view the
other view is that
you can build some other skills as you
go
along i say i'll give an example so for
instance
if you are very good let's say as a
strategic thinker if you can think very
strategically
then there is no point in becoming
better and better at that
i think you are will be able to leverage
your strategic thinking if you improve
your execution skills a little bit
because just by being an armchair
strategy thinker people lose respect for
you
you can gain respect and create impact
of your strategic picking only if you
learn to execute well
so i think you know if you learn some
complementary skills around your core
strength
then i think you are able to you know do
completely different things so i think
your course
may likely remain the same but if you
can build complementary skills
so for example if you are clear thinker
can you become a better communicator
if you're a strategic thinker can you
become better at execution
so if you can just add these
complementarities then you can become an
amazing individual
sorry i think our time is up but there
are a lot of interesting interesting
questions maybe we can ask them to just
uh send it uh separately and see if we
can
answer them offline so thank you
everyone i think it was a
lovely uh hearing from all of you i
think some of these questions were
really really very interesting
unfortunately we couldn't take all the
questions but please do send them
we will upload this webinar on our page
you can write these questions there also
and we'll try to answer them
offline as well thank you everyone have
a good night thank you harry it was
really
thank you thank you thanks bye good
night
just a reminder to everyone uh
our next simply learn webinar
is on next thursday september 17th
leadership webinar what does it take to
be part of a global marketing team today
with sandeep menon the senior director
uh senior marketing director of google
so please check that out and join us
and we look forward to seeing you then
and you can follow simply learn on
facebook
twitter and linkedin and you can also
follow
hari on linkedin as well
thanks again
[Music]
you